un bon soir mardi 29 septembre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 c'est
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale tout
de suite les titres de cette édition des
tables rondes conférences et ateliers
pour faciliter la transition digital les
assises du numérique se tenait
aujourd'hui à montigny le bretonneux
un rendez vous pour les élus alto
séquanais yvelinois organisé par seine
et yvelines numériques
son directeur général délégué et laurent
rochette est notre invité est depuis la
fin août ce conteneur est installé dans
le quartier du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie c'est une plate forme
originale d'accès à l'emploi les
candidats peuvent s'y rendre sans cv ni
lettre de motivation pour trouver un job
ou être informé et puis cette
performance le week end dernier à saint
germain en laye fabrice pancrazi a couru
45 heures sur un tapis roulant une
course de 160 km et 10000 mètres de
dénivelé au profit de l'association
vaincre la mucoviscidose
à suivre également dans un instant un
reportage sur un atelier de bande
dessinée avec des personnes condamnées
ou suivie par la justice c'est en vue du
27e festival de la bd de buco programme
en octobre prochain
[Musique]
et j'accueille d'emblée sur ce plateau
laurent rochette bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur délégué général
délégué de seine et yvelines numériques
l'opérateur public interdépartemental
organisée ce mardi les assises du
numérique
c'était à la ferme du manet à montigny
le bretonneux le numérique qui est
omniprésent dans nos vies et suscite
encore quelques interrogations notamment
chez les élus regarder ce sujet d'astrid
bergère comment réussir la
transformation digitale de nos
territoires c'était tout l'objet des
troisièmes assises du numérique
parmi les thèmes abordés lissante et la
sûreté urbaine la dématérialisation ou
encore le numérique pour l'éducation et
cette année ces sujets ont une résonance
particulière pendant évidemment la crise
sanitaire elle confinement qu'on a
connus on a vu que le numérique prenez
vraiment une place prépondérante dans la
vie des citoyens
la première table ronde était consacrée
au numérique pour l'éducation
raccordement à la fibre très haut débit
ou achat de vidéoprojecteurs interactifs
les établissements opère un tournant et
depuis 2000 15 18 collèges des yvelines
participent à un projet pilote grâce
auquel dix mille élèves et 1000
professeurs ont reçu des tablettes un
des souhaits était de travailler le
passage du manuel scolaire papier
traditionnel un ensemble de ressources
numériques dont les manuels scolaires
numériques pourquoi pas cette table
ronde était donc l'occasion entre autres
de faire le bilan de ce projet pilote
qui s'achève cette année pour les élèves
la joute d'appareils numériques comme la
tablette en plus des outils papier
semble bénéfique
la tablette leur sert pour
leurs cours la tablette leur sert moment
des examens aussi puisque nous avons
intégré dans l'oral de soutenance du
brevet des collèges
le fait qu'il soit en mesure de montrer
un usage pertinent de leurs outils
numériques et cela va aussi développer
des ambitions personnelles chez les
élèves
le bilan est d'autant plus positif pour
cet établissement qu'élèves et
professeurs ou utiliser la tablette
pendant tout le confinement ça nous a
permis de garder du lien véritablement
avec nos élèves et de continuer un
travail de qualité sap a juste été un
pis-aller
moi je dis souvent aux mains amusant
mais comme on n'avait pas les scories du
quotidien eh ben pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans j'ai terminé mon programme
en troisième en lettres au total plus de
400 personnes ont participé à ces
troisièmes assises du numérique
voilà pour ces assises du numérique avec
un focus vous l'avez vu sur lies
éducation mais pas que ça a été dit
laurent rochette dans le sujet ce sont
des assises du numérique interviennent
dans un contexte particulier la crise
sanitaire le confinement aussi où
forcément les les français utilisaient
davantage leur connexion internet pour
rester en lien avec leurs familles leurs
proches
est ce qu'à votre avis les une prise de
conscience de tous les enjeux du
numérique cette année
ou est ce qu'elle n'est pas nouvelle
finalement cette prise de conscience ont
elles été un peu sous jacente depuis
déjà un certain temps mais je dirais
qu'elle a pris une certaine matérialité
effectivement à l'occasion du
confinement
on a bien vu que sans le numérique il
n'aurait pas pu se passer grand chose
que ce soit pour les élèves à l'école
les actifs en matière de télétravail ou
même les seniors qui ont pu garder une
forme de contact avec leurs familles au
travers du numérique si on revient sur
les objectifs de ce rendez vous il est
adressé aux élus aux collectivités c'est
pour leur dire emparez vous de ces
sujets on ne peut pas faire sans le
numérique aujourd'hui absolument
on est à un moment particulier puisque
pour ce qui concerne en tout cas les les
élus communaux et intercommunaux donc ce
qu'on a l'habitude d'appeler le bloc
communal les élus se trouve un début de
mandat donc qu'ils sont en train de
mettre en oeuvre un projet de mandate
qu'ils ont pu le définir où le présenter
devant leurs électeurs et dans cette
mise en oeuvre l'idée c'est
effectivement de leur proposer une
collaboration de s'appuyer sur seine
yvelines numériques qui est un outil de
mutualisation et d' expertise de manière
à leur faire gagner du temps et de
gagner en efficience financière comme
opérationnel d'autant que si on est à la
tête d'une commune c'est une thématique
transversale ça va concerner l'éducation
la vue d'un sujet aussi la sécurité les
télécommunications c'est vraiment
transversale cette thématique du
numérique
oui c'est d'ailleurs l'objectif de ces
assises 2020 précédemment nous avions
déjà tenu deux fois des assises qui
était très tournée vers le lit éducation
et nous avons souhaité bien sûr
continuer à parler d éducation on a bien
vu la cohésion de confinement quelle
importance elle avait mais aussi élargir
sur d'autres thématiques
d'ailleurs si on dresse un premier bilan
et skull et les élus étaient au
rendez-vous aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils
étaient intéressés par ces thématiques
alors je vous cache pas que dans le
contexte qui est le nôtre nous nous
interrogions sur la participation réelle
que nous allions à voir au delà des
quelques 400 inscrits et nous avons une
participation massive puisque la
quasi-totalité des inscrits étaient
présents et quelques personnes sont
venues sont forcément avoir été inscrit
donc on a dépassé ce seuil des 400
inscrits ce qui démontre bien encore une
fois dans cette période que le numérique
la transition numérique l'intégration du
numérique dans le quotidien des uns et
des autres est une thématique est
extrêmement importante pour les élus
quelques mots sur seine et yvelines
numériques qui est un syndicat mixte
ouvert qui a été créée en 2016 alors à
l'origine s'appelait yvelines numériques
mais depuis le 1er janvier le 1er
janvier de cette année vous êtes élargi
en plus des yvelines aux hauts de seine
oui or d'abord le
lesnumeriques ray en 2016 c'est la
volonté du département et des
intercommunalités hesdinoise de
constituer une plate forme d' expertise
et de mutualisation techniques et des
ressources pour encore une fois
finalement faire que la dépense publique
soit plus efficiente et qu'on trouve
facilement de l' expertise et vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que les
présidents des deux départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine ont
engagé il ya maintenant plusieurs années
un projet de rapprochement qui nous a
concerné effectivement 1er janvier
puisque le département des
hauts-de-seine est venu rejoindre les
adhérents 10 lits numérique devenue
scène est venu mais c'est donc un
doublement viread de périmètre et de la
surface du syndicat qui couvre désormais
3 millions d'habitants avec un objectif
principal aussi pour le syndicat c'était
le déploiement de la fibre optique sur
le territoire l'objectif était pour voir
en très haut débit le territoire
yvelinois d'ici la fin 2020 est ce que
on est dans les temps ou finalement est
ce que cette crise sanitaire a fait
prendre du retard dans ce projet alors
on n'est pas encore à la fin d'année
donc de faire la jauge de la mesure de
la jauge maintenant pour décembre
c'était un peu compliqué néanmoins sur
ce territoire rural yvelinois la mesure
que nous avons fait au mois de septembre
du déploiement engagé par l'opérateur
tdf dépasse l'engagement qu'ils étaient
pris pour septembre
en clair tdf été engagés pour septembre
a déployé 70% des prises dans les foyers
est le chiffre qui a été relevé sur le
terrain et de 76%
on voit bien que tous les feux sont au
vert pour que l'objectif soit atteint à
la fin de l'année maintenant on va
rester prudent et on va attendre la fin
de l'année locaux vides d'un
manifestement pas retarder les
déploiements même s'il a sans doute
compliquer le travail de tdf donc le
l'autre objectif c'est aussi de
développer les services numériques sur
le territoire faisait pour ce faire une
centrale d'achat qui permet de
simplifier les achats pour les élus pour
les collectivités c'est absolument ce
que nous avons noté c'est que la
commande que nous passait le département
par exemple en matière d éducation pour
équiper des collégiens générait des
volumes tellement important que nous
pouvions en faire bénéficier le bloc
communal puis
maintenant également le département des
hauts-de-seine et les communes des
hauts-de-seine
donc à un moment donné plutôt que de
passer des marchés pour le pour le seul
département avec des volumes importants
nous avons constitué une centrale
d'achat qui est ouverte aux au bloc
communal et qui compte maintenant plus
de 70 à dire donc voilà pour cette
centrale d'achat juste un dernier mot
nous reste moins d'une minute sur les
dossiers en cours pour céder vie
numérique on parle beaucoup de la 5g est
ce que c'est un dossier qui vous
concerne vous ou pas du tout est ce que
vous êtes tourné vers d'autres
oui c'est un dossier qui nous concerne
sur lequel on est en train de regarder
quelle position nous pourrons avoir sur
le sujet alors pas de position
idéologique
j'irai dans le contexte actuel mais en
termes de déploiement pour nous il ya
deux ans je le premier c'est la 5g va
nécessiter beaucoup plus de points euro
et donc il ya lieu de regarder comment
on peut jouer peut-être un rôle de
régulateur sur l'implantation de deux
ses points hauts en insistant les
communes d'une part mais aussi des
opérateurs qui ont toujours du mal à
trouver des points aux nouveaux et puis
la 5g va jouer un rôle dans tout ce
qu'on appelle smart cities c'est à dire
la capacité de connecter des capteurs
terrain et donc on va regarder aussi
bien l'un que l'autre de ces deux sujets
merci laurent rochette d'être venu en
plateau merci à vous rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur général délégué de
seine et yvelines numériques
dans l'actualité également nous avons
appris cette disparition
hier andré sylvestre ex-maire de
magnanville est décédé samedi à l'âge de
79 ans il avait été le premier magistrat
de la commune pendant 31 entre 1983 et
2014 conseiller général des yvelines
également et de 2001 à 2015 ancien
instituteur andré sylvestre avait pour
habitude de terminer tous ses discours
par un poème
le mois dernier les yvelines ont
enregistré un chômage qui progressait de
4,45 % pour la catégorie a dans le
département pour faciliter l'accès à
l'emploi et des solutions originales
aussi émergent comme ce conteneur qui
est installé depuis la fin août sur le
parking de la dalle du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie il est proposé par la
société cap jobs est les détails avec ce
sujet d'eléonore sinoquet de célia gars
de son go un conteneur c'est le lieu
insolite que le groupement d'employeurs
clé jobs a installé depuis fin août dans
le quartier du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie
objectif permettre aux jeunes de trouver
un emploi ou une formation
pourquoi une boîte métallique parce que
c'est peut-être le format le plus ouvert
en tout cas c'est ce que nous avons
trouvé c'est à dire pour être un plus
hors les murs pour être plus ouverts à
tous les publics
pour justement attirer même parfois par
curiosité mais de toute façon tous ceux
qui nous approchent sont concernés d'une
manière ou d'une autre par l'emploi ou
la formation appelée kiosque pour
l'emploi est installée jusqu'à fin 2000
21 municipalités et entreprises espèrent
repéré mille jeunes et réaliser 100 à
150 embauches directes
c'est une bonne chose parce qu'ici on
est au coeur du quartier du val fourré
l'endroit où il ya le plus de chômage à
mantes la jolie et notamment chez les
jeunes et donc le fait d'être en hyper
proximité et surtout de proposer des
offres d'emploi immédiatement
disponibles suite à un procès ce qui est
en train d'être rodé ça permet de
répondre tout de suite aux demandes
d'emploi pour le préfet délégué à
l'égalité des chances ce concept
s'inscrit dans le plan de relance mis en
place par le gouvernement dont un tiers
des actions concernent l'accès à
l'emploi des jeunes il faut des
initiatives comme ça partout dans sur
territoire pour montrer aux jeunes des
quartiers que l'accès à l'emploi est
possible que l'accès l'emploi est pas
réservé aux autres que c'est pas
toujours pour les autres que la
république tient ses promesses mais que
c'est pour tout le monde et notamment et
surtout pour les pour eux qui en ont
plus particulièrement besoin
une douzaine de concepts similaires sont
ou seront installés dans la région
parisienne dans les yvelines un autre
conteneur sera bientôt disponible dans
la gare de versailles chantiers
c'est justement dans une dynamique
d'insertion et aussi pour redonner
confiance en soi qui est organisé depuis
trois ans maintenant sept ateliers au
programme de la bande dessinée avec des
personnes placées sous main de justice
il était organisé il ya quelques jours
au château de buc en vue du 27e festival
de la bande dessinée qui est prévu dans
la commune en octobre astrid bergère et
marie pas neutre a pour la troisième
année consécutive le château de buc
accueille des personnes placées sous
main de justice pour des ateliers trois
hommes condamnés laissés libres se sont
retrouvés avec un auteur le but échanger
entre eux et découvrir le monde de la bd
on est plutôt sur des personnes voilà
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de faire ce
genre d'activités qui ont peut-être pas
habitués n'ont pu faire des activités
socialisant tout est dans des
associations et puis aussi des personnes
par une mauvaise image d'elle-même
voilà est dans quelque chose de
valorisant partir du principe que
certains savent pas dessiner et au bout
de deux jours bas ils savent faire
quelque chose les participants viennent
sur la base du volontariat
à l'issue des deux jours d'ateliers une
affiche commune est réalisé dans la bd
on trouve tout c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui qui qui rassemble toutes les
générations tous les styles c'est
ludique
alors on a l'impression que juste des
bulles avec des dessins mais pas du tout
il ya une recherche il ya une vraie une
vraie technique c'est tellement vaste
c'est tellement riche que je pense que
tout le monde y trouve son compte
cet atelier profite bien sûr aux
participants mais pas que l'auteur
encadrant aussi il trouve son compte
depuis maintenant trois ans c'est le
dessinateur et rock à qui on doit
notamment la bd les profs qui conduit
l'atelier parce que ça peut m'apporter
mois va justement c'est de voir d'autres
gens que le public habituel de la bd
parce que on est toujours on est dans un
petit milieu un peu fermé hier les fans
de bd les enfants qui lisent mes bd que
je connais je sais ce qui leur plaît ou
pas dans mes bd dont cinq espèces de
ronds qui fait que là c'est différent la
joie des gens qui s'intéressent pas
forcément la bd et ça m'apporte déjà des
contacts différents
un atelier qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
du festival de la bd dubuc
il aura lieu les 10 et 11 octobre 2020
cent mille euros pour la commune de la
verrière le chèque a été remis cette
semaine par l ile de france dans le
cadre de son contrat d'aménagement
régional cette somme va être utilisé
pour la réfection de la voirie en centre
ville et aussi pour la réhabilitation de
l'ancienne pmi en crèche elle les
travaux du bâtiment situé tout près du
scarabée ont déjà débuté et devraient se
terminer au printemps 2021 la crèche
accueillera 45 berceau autre projet mais
qui lui fait débat dans le nord des
yvelines le conseil départemental veut
créer une voie de contournement de la
route départementale 154 l'objectif
s'est délesté lé centre ville du trafic
de transit une réalisation qui va
impacter les communes de vernouillet
verneuil sur seine et de chapais une
réunion publique se tenait en fin de
semaine dernière les précisions
d'eléonore sinoquet pour ou contre
voilà ce que les trois maires de
verneuil sur seine
1 nous y ait échappé demandent à leurs
habitants ils ont lancé une consultation
publique autour du projet de déviation
de la route départementale 154 qui
traversera le bois de verneuil le début
du chantier est prévue pour fin 2020 les
trois élus ont donc organisé une réunion
publique afin d'en débattre
le maire de chapais lui est ouvertement
contre ses deux confrères n'ont pas pris
position
chapelle complètement congestionnée
chapais complètement à saturation aux
heures de pointe
mais maintenant ça va complètement
empirer et donc au niveau purement
chapet toi les lectures de la carte nous
montre que cette déviation est une
catastrophe
mon objectif c'est de trancher 60 ans de
débats il y à des personnes de malice
qui sont pour cette route d'autres qui
sont contre cette route je leur laisse
leur liberté de parole en tant que maire
de la ville
c'est j'ai pas d'avis tranché il ya des
avantages et des inconvénients selon la
partie du territoire
si on habite dans le bas de la ville le
boulevard de l'europe au jugé
aujourd'hui est une vraie vraie fracture
urbaine
elle divise le quartier du parc en deux
par contre on a une plaine agricole
donc si cette départementale est
construite ça sera une autre fracture
urbaine qui sera construite dans la
plaine agricole
quelle que soit leur point de vue les
trois élus ont promis de s'aligner sur
la vie des habitants des avis qui était
évidemment partagé lors de cette réunion
publique
la consultation se fera en deux fois
d'abord numérique du 1er au 8 octobre
tu es en vote physique sera organisé
dans les trois municipalités le 11
octobre mais rien ne garantit toutefois
que les élus du département qui n'était
pas présent lors de la réunion tiennent
compte des résultats de cette
consultation
on prend maintenant la direction de
saint-germain-en-laye pour cette
performance retentissante un ultra ultra
trailer fabrice prend crasy a couru
durant trois jours 45 heures sur un
tapis roulant au profit de l'association
vaincre la mucoviscidose
c'était le week-end dernier à l'occasion
de la virade des rois retour avec
michael et demi d'euros ils première
mondiale à saint germain les installer
sur un tapis roulant devant le château
l'ultra trailer fabrice pancrazi a
parcouru 160 kilomètres avec 10000
mètres de dénivelé sur trois jours cette
performance inédite a été organisée
pendant la virade des rois pour vaincre
la mucoviscidose
je vous avoue je suis totalement et
fusées j'ai dormi une heure la nuit
dernière
avant-hier et 2h cette nuit et je
dormais dans ma voiture qui est juste en
face donc je suis totalement épuisé et
puis il ya l'effort physique qui est
extrêmement difficile puisque sur un
tapis on fait toujours le même geste
ça veut donc dire que ce sont toujours
les mêmes muscles qu'il travaille
pendant ces quarante cinq heures
d'efforts de ce vendredi 25 au dimanche
27 septembre sportif a également pu
partager cette aventure avec de nombreux
passants grâce un deuxième tapis
installés juste à côté de lui
l'idée était aussi de faire participer
les gens qui donnent aussi à
le public et puis les amis qui viennent
encourager et donc un tapis et ils l'ont
accompagnée elle a aussi avec des
exploits des gens qui ont fait 30 km de
nuit
à plus de 10 km heure de moyenne
au total l'ultra trail de fabrice a
permis de récolter plus de 9000 euros
vous pouvez continuer à faire vos dons à
l'association pendant encore un mois par
téléphone un ebe noah à roland garros le
saint germanois arthur rinderknecht
était hier sur la terre battue
parisienne le 162e joueur mondial
bénéficié d'une wild card c'est une
invitation pour disputer son premier
tournoi du grand chelem à 25 ans
malheureusement pour lui la route
s'arrête dès le premier tour défaite
après trois heures 23 minutes de jeu
face au slovène aljaz bedene en quatre
sets 6 2 6 7 6 4 6 4
arthur in darkness n'est pas parvenu à
profiter du gain de la deuxième manche
mais a tout de même fait bonne figure
face aux 56e mondiale il est encore
engagé à roland garros en double il
jouera demain dans un instant nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture sur tv 78 avec aux
manettes justin brasier bonsoir bonsoir
alors de quoi allez vous nous parler ce
soir eh bien on parlera de l'exposition
d'alésia rome qui s'est installée au
musée d'archéologie nationale et elle
retrace l'aventuré archéologique de
napoléon iii
et puis la commanderie fait aussi nuit
blanche de nombreuses animations sont
prévues exposition vidéo interactive
accroc danse et puis le festival de bd
de buc revient au château dédicaces
rencontres avec les auteurs et
exposition vous attendons merci justin
le cetud culture c'est dans un instant
c'est à partir de 18h30 sur tv 78 voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée à tous sur
tv 78
[Musique]